NATO peacekeepers have been in Kosovo
for more than 20 years and more are on
the way
[Music]
they're there to keep the peace between
kosovo's majority Albanian population
and its minority ethnic serbs mostly in
the North
but that peace has been hard to keep in
recent days a Kosovo police officer was
shot and killed last week at a
checkpoint in Northern Kosovo which led
to a shootout at a monastery that killed
three ethnic Serb gunmen
Kosovo is accusing the Serbian
government of being behind that attack
accusations denied by Belgrade what
happened in the north of Kosovo was an
arm attacked by paramilitary forces that
have been paid trained aided and abetted
by Serbia
[Applause]
the recent troubles began earlier this
year when ethnic serbs boycotted local
elections which saw ethnic Albanian maze
installed in the region
they were protests and unrest in
response
Kosovo declared its independence in 2008
a move rejected by Belgrade which
considers Kosovo a breakaway province
the recent unrest has raised further
tension in the ethnically divided region
the very
most important safety for Kosovo
sanctions for Serbia and then we can
talk about an agreement and good
neighborly relations
the United States is monitoring what it
says is a large Serbian military
deployment on the border with Kosovo
while its top Diplomat put in a call to
Belgrade
I had a long phone conversation not an
easy one with U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken regarding the situation
in Kosovo there's a few things we agreed
on and a few things we did not agree on
we did agree there's a need for
de-escalation and a greater role for
NATO peacekeeping forces there
[Music]
in the face of expanding NATO prisons
known as K foreign Kosovo one Belgrade
based analyst says all-out conflict is
unlikely
both sides are severely deterred from
escalating this Beyond repair but also
at the same time it means that if either
of the sides was to escalate
substantially K4 and the International
Community more generally would be able
to respond quickly and swiftly
last week's violence Remains the worst
in years it comes at a time when the
European Union and U.S officials are
trying to strike a deal in the hopes of
finding lasting peace in the region
Mike level Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera